Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
¿Eres tan bueno para las cosas
como crees que eres?
¿Qué tan bueno eres
para administrar el dinero?
¿Y para leer las emociones
de las personas?
¿Qué tan saludable eres respecto
de otras personas que conoces?
¿Eres mejor en gramática
que el promedio?
Saber lo competente que somos
y cómo son nuestras habilidades
en relación con las de las otras personas
es más que un impulso de autoestima.
Nos ayuda a descubrir cuándo podemos
seguir con nuestras decisiones e instintos
y cuándo necesitamos,
en cambio, buscar consejo.
Pero la investigación psicológica
sugiere que no somos muy buenos
para autoevaluarnos con precisión.
De hecho, frecuentemente sobreestimamos
nuestras propias habilidades.
Los investigadores tienen un nombre
para este fenómeno:
el efecto Dunning-Kruger.
Este efecto explica
por qué más de 100 estudios
han demostrado que las personas
muestran una superioridad ilusoria.
Nos juzgamos a nosotros mismos
como mejores que otros
en un grado que viola
las leyes de las matemáticas.
Dos empresas pidieron a los ingenieros
de software que calificaran su desempeño
y el 32 % de los ingenieros de
una empresa y el 42 % de la otra
se autoposicionaron entre el mejor 5 %.
En otro estudio el 88 %
de los conductores de EE.UU.
se autodescribieron con habilidades
de conducción por encima del promedio.
Estos no son hallazgos aislados.
En promedio, las personas tienden
a calificarse como mejores que la mayoría
en disciplinas que van de la salud,
a habilidades de liderazgo, ética y demás.
Resulta de particular interés
que quienes tienen la menor habilidad
son a menudo los más propensos
a sobrevalorar sus habilidades.
Las personas con pobre
razonamiento lógico,
gramática,
conocimiento financiero,
matemática,
inteligencia emocional,
que hace pruebas de laboratorio médico,
y ajedrez
tienden a calificar su experiencia
casi tan favorablemente como los expertos.
Entonces, ¿quién es más vulnerable
a este engaño?
Tristemente, todos, porque
todos tenemos incompetencias
que no reconocemos.
Pero ¿por qué?
Cuando los psicólogos Dunning y Kruger
descubrieron el efecto en 1999,
argumentaron que quienes desconocen o
no tienen habilidad en áreas particulares
sufren una doble maldición.
Primero, cometen errores
y llegan a decisiones pobres.
Pero segundo, esas mismas lagunas
también impiden que capten sus errores.
Es decir, quien tiene rendimiento pobre,
carece de la experiencia necesaria
para reconocer lo mal que lo hace.
Por ejemplo, cuando
los investigadores estudiaron
participantes en un torneo
de debate universitario,
el 25 % inferior de los equipos
en las rondas preliminares
perdieron casi cuatro
de cada cinco partidos.
Pero pensaron que
estaban ganando casi el 60 %.
Sin una fuerte comprensión
de las reglas de debate,
los estudiantes simplemente no podían
reconocer cuándo o con qué frecuencia
argumentaban de forma endeble.
El efecto Dunning-Kruger no es cuestión
de ego que encubre nuestras debilidades.
Las personas por lo general admiten
sus carencias cuando las ven.
En un estudio los estudiantes que
hicieron mal un cuestionario lógico
y luego tomaron un mini curso de lógica
estaban bastante dispuestos a tildar
de horribles sus actuaciones iniciales.
Por eso las personas
con moderada experiencia
a menudo tienen menos confianza
en sus habilidades.
Saben suficiente como para saber
que hay mucho que no saben.
Por otro lado, los expertos suelen
ser conscientes de lo que saben.
Pero a menudo cometen un error diferente:
suponen que todos los demás
también saben.
El resultado es que las personas,
sean ineptos o altamente cualificados,
a menudo quedan atrapadas en una burbuja
de autopercepción inexacta.
Cuando no son expertos,
no pueden ver sus propias fallas.
Cuando son excepcionalmente competentes,
no perciben cuán inusuales
son sus habilidades.
Entonces, si el efecto Dunning-Kruger
es invisible para quienes lo experimentan,
¿qué puedes hacer para descubrir
qué tan bueno eres en varias cosas?
Primero, solicita comentarios
de otras personas,
y tenlos en cuenta, aunque
sean difíciles de escuchar.
Segundo, y más importante,
sigue aprendiendo.
Cuanto más conocemos,
menos probable es que tengamos agujeros
invisibles en nuestra competencia.
Quizá todo se reduce
a ese viejo proverbio:
Cuando discutes con un tonto,
primero asegúrate de que la otra persona
no esté haciendo lo mismo.